he was hired to win but they won't stop
talking about his skin mike mcdaniel the
new head coach of the miami dolphins
says the hyper focus on this race is
weird the team announced their new hire
yesterday amid controversy surrounding
the termination of previous head coach
brian flores flores a black man is suing
the nfl for racial discrimination i
wonder mike tell the truth has it been
very odd
it's been very odd to tell you the truth
this idea of identifying as something i
identify as a human being i've never
and my dad's black it's weird that it
comes up because i've just tried to
be a good person i don't have any
um real experience with with racism i
know my my mom experienced it when she
uh married my dad i know my dad
experienced it and that's in my family
but
um
i guess that makes me uh
a human being that can identify with
other people's problems
wow identifies as a human being where do
you get off
you can't do that today you got to take
off a box and join a team or just like
that default thumbs up emoji you're
racist and you'll be in good company
with the woke sports site dead spin
back in january their lazy writers
published a hit piece on mike referring
to him as just another young white guy
not qualified to be a head coach they
argue the nfl should focus on black
candidates more deserving of the job
after learning mcdaniel was in fact
biracial they were forced to update the
story days later so good for mike for
not playing the identity politics game
but here's a crazy idea hire him and let
him prove if he's qualified or not i'm
not saying coaching football is an easy
job but i've seen 12 year olds who are
amazing at playing madden
and chances are there's always going to
be someone more deserving of a job than
the person hired especially if you're
the president of the united states
see how i worked a little anti-bite
stuff into there tyrus huh you like that
well done thank you thank you that's why
you know i make the big bucks around
here you know i go to you first only
because you know you played football
yeah that's what me and i appreciate
that listen i i get it the brother's
confusing to some people i'm confusing
light skin's a little uncomfortable for
some people and
i feel for the brother because he is
about as light-skinned as you get you
know like
you know he if he said he wasn't you
weren't probably going to argue with him
right but that's not even the point
he just got the job
and he's trying to say
dude i just got hired yeah can you ask
me about the
black stuff in like a month like i just
got here
like
can you ask me like how does it feel to
get my first giant opportunity like this
or what my plan is that's what he
planned on for and he was
he tried to do the best thing he could
and it actually probably hurt him more
than but i mean look at his little frail
hands he's a little you know
he's the last guy that i thought would
be a head coach to be honest i can't
wait to see how big that headset's on
him
but i will support the brother but you
know he's he comes from a good family
yes and he he comes from an affluent
family and so he didn't go through a lot
of the things and there's a lot of
brothers and sisters who went who come
from good homes who don't always go
through this stuff so when they finally
gets dropped in the lap they're appalled
yeah just like there's a lot of white
people grow up dirt poor and we're
treated just as bad and they have so
it's not always about the color of your
skin it's where you grew up and what you
what what your environment was and that
goes against the woke yeah and they want
to discredit him because he's smart and
he he doesn't have a beanie on he didn't
say you know what i'm saying you know
what word because he didn't grow up
you're the sound of your voice is from
your neighborhood has nothing to do with
your skin tone you know that's a great
point like
is it cultural or racial right because
those two things get completed right and
like when it talks about the lack of
representation i think it's more about
bringing up the cultural side than it is
the racial side i really do and when you
see a lot of these like this guy's being
attacked
really i mean because he doesn't present
himself a certain way and you know you
could see he was really struggling just
to stretch it and just to like appea and
just to talk to them and be he was
stretching he was trying to push for an
answer to give them but why do we have
to cave to the paranoid you know race
mongers in the crowd who were just
always looking to have a fight about
something and they're basically racial
bullies right i mean so
we get it we get that it's an issue but
this guy he just proved he's like can we
just move on can the whole country move
on yeah he's damned if he does damn does
he doesn't that article it was crazy
that guy really he really thought he had
something there and just reading it
with the correction
you think about like so what does that
mean about the author's point like that
he half deserves it yeah like it doesn't
make if you follow his premise it sounds
ridiculous but that's exactly what he's
saying well cat you co you identify as a
half veteran i am i do yeah yeah
married i'm half a veteran you get
married to a veteran you become half a
veteran it's math and i'm also half a
veteran
for different reasons
you work for that house
or he saved that half you saved that app
yes
oh my god
isn't it funny when the media doesn't
like you they take your blackness away
because they'd never take barack obama's
away no or mine yeah but because
he didn't fit what they needed with the
argument they took it away from him yeah
that's a great point to get rid of him
canceling this black part yes
coming up more people pretend they're
hulk hogan while trying to strong-arm
joe rogan
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else